Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The day was mild. A cloudless sky lay over the broad chestnut trees. It was a day made to be happy. The vacation days would soon set in for the people and children, and on this holiday they anticipated the entire summer with its fresh air, its lush green, and the forgetting of all daily cares. I was sitting at some distance from the crowd in the park reading a book. Nevertheless, I was simultaneously aware of the wind in the trees, the chirping of the birds, and the music which was wafted toward me from the park. And so it was that I suddenly stopped reading when the music broke off abruptly.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。那是一个温和的日子。万里无云的天空笼罩着宽阔的栗树。这是一个注定要快乐的日子。人们和孩子们很快就要迎来假期，在这个节日里，他们期待着整个夏天，期待着清新的空气、郁郁葱葱的绿色，以及忘却所有的日常烦恼。我坐在公园里离人群稍远的地方看书。尽管如此，我同时也能感觉到树间的微风、鸟儿的鸣叫，以及从公园飘向我的音乐。就这样，当音乐戛然而止时，我突然停止了阅读。
I did not know what piece the band was playing. I noticed only that the music had broken off. Instinctively, I looked up from my book. The crowd which strolled through the trees as a single light-moving mass also seemed to have undergone a change. It too had suddenly come to a halt. Something must have happened. So that was Stefan Zweig in The World of Yesterday, and he is describing the afternoon of Sunday, the 28th of June, 1914. He was reading in a park in Baden, just outside Vienna. And of course course the something that has happened is the news arriving of the assassination of archduke franz ferdinand in sarajevo and he posted this manuscript just before he committed suicide in 1942 at the height of the Second World War, the Nazi tyranny.
我不知道乐队在演奏什么曲子。我只注意到音乐中断了。我本能地从书中抬起头来。那群在树间漫步、如同一团轻盈移动的人群似乎也发生了变化。他们也突然停了下来。一定发生了什么事。以上就是斯蒂芬·茨威格在《昨日的世界》中的描述，他正在描写1914年6月28日星期日的下午。他当时正在维也纳郊外的巴登公园里看书。当然，所谓“发生了什么事”，就是传来了奥匈帝国皇储弗朗茨·斐迪南在萨拉热窝遇刺的消息。他在1942年第二次世界大战、纳粹暴政达到顶峰时，在自杀前不久寄出了这份手稿。
And so he is writing about that moment as the great hinge in recent history, the moment that opens up the horrors not just of the trenches and the collapse of the Habsburg Empire, but also the coming of the Nazis and the seeming destruction of European civilization. So, Dominic, the day that we are about to describe is a day that matters as much, perhaps, as any day in the whole course of history. Absolutely. Do you think that's going too far?
因此，他将那一刻写成近代史上巨大的转折点，这一刻不仅开启了战壕和哈布斯堡帝国崩溃的恐怖，也开启了纳粹的到来以及欧洲文明看似毁灭的序幕。那么，多米尼克，我们即将描述的这一天，在整个历史进程中，或许和任何一天一样重要。绝对是这样。你觉得这说法太夸张了吗？
No, I don't think it's going too far at all, Tom. Lots of people will say, oh, of course, the First World War would have happened anyway, or a war would have happened anyway. Zweig in his wonderful book, which gives a portrait of the world that was destroyed, the pre-1914 world, he obviously takes this moment in the park, as you said, as the dividing line between civilization and barbarism. And for people of his generation, of course, he's Jewish. It was. yeah afterwards nothing would be the same again the the world the civilization that the common society of central europe was destroyed that afternoon
不，汤姆，我不觉得太夸张。很多人会说，哦，当然，第一次世界大战无论如何都会发生，或者战争无论如何都会发生。茨威格在他那本精彩的书中，描绘了一个被摧毁的世界——1914年之前的世界，正如你所说，他显然把公园里的这一刻视为文明与野蛮之间的分界线。对于他那一代人来说，当然，他是犹太人。确实如此。在那之后，一切都将不再一样，那个世界、那个文明、那个中欧的共同社会，在那个下午被摧毁了。
i mean there's also another great writer who's a citizen of the hapsburg empire and jewish which is franz kafka yes great short story writer in his diary, there is no mention of it at all. And in a way that I find just as moving that he is carrying on his life. He's not noticing it. Right. He's unaware. I mean, if he is aware, it's not important to him to note it down. But of course, that will overwhelm him just as much. Yeah. Whether you notice it or not, it makes no difference. It doesn't make any difference, exactly. And I think you're absolutely right. It's a day that deserves real consideration.
我的意思是，还有另一位伟大的作家，他也是哈布斯堡帝国的公民，也是犹太人，那就是弗朗茨·卡夫卡。是的，伟大的短篇小说家。在他的日记里，根本没有提到这件事。在某种程度上，我觉得这同样令人动容，他继续过着自己的生活。他没有注意到。没错。他不知道。我的意思是，如果他知道，对他来说记录下来并不重要。但当然，这同样会淹没他。是的。无论你是否注意到，都没有区别。确实没有任何区别。而且我认为你说得完全正确。这是值得真正深思的一天。
So we should give it the detail it deserves. Even before Franz Ferdinand set foot in Sarajevo, the 28th of June was a special day. It's a special day for him and Sophie, his wife, who is, of course, also killed that day. It's the anniversary of the day on which he swore the oath of renunciation in which he basically gave up the throne for his future children
所以我们应该给予它应有的细节。甚至在弗朗茨·斐迪南踏入萨拉热窝之前，6月28日就是一个特殊的日子。对他和他的妻子索菲来说，这是一个特殊的日子，当然，索菲也在那天遇害了。这是他宣誓放弃继承权的日子，在那次宣誓中，他基本上为他未来的孩子们放弃了王位。
and made this morganatic marriage with sophie it's not his wedding anniversary which some historians say was but it is an important date for an incredibly important day a really poignant day actually isn't it it's the day of his humiliation but it's also the day that made it impossible for him to have happiness with his wife yeah but also for a lot of people in sarajevo it's a very important day because it's saint vitus's day vidovdan as they call it it is the anniversary of the battle of kosovo in 1389 when when Serbia was overwhelmed by the Ottomans. And on that day, a Serbian knight called Miloš Oblič assassinated the sultan, Murad I.
并与索菲缔结了这场贵庶通婚。这不是他们的结婚纪念日，尽管有些历史学家说是，但对于一个极其重要的日子来说，这是一个重要的日期，实际上是一个非常令人心酸的日子，不是吗？这是他受辱的日子，但也是让他无法与妻子获得幸福的日子。是的，但对萨拉热窝的许多人来说，这也是一个非常重要的日子，因为这是圣维特日（Vidovdan），正如他们所称的那样。这是1389年科索沃战役的周年纪念日，当时塞尔维亚被奥斯曼帝国征服。在那一天，一位名叫米洛什·奥比利奇的塞尔维亚骑士刺杀了苏丹穆拉德一世。
And that moment becomes one of almost mystical significance to Serbs. It has significance, of course, to this day, Tom, which is why Kosovo is still such a live issue right now in the 21st century. Right. So it's potentially incredibly inflammatory. Has anyone kind of advised the Archduke that maybe it's not the best day to be driving in an open car through the streets of Sarajevo? People have discussed it. They have talked about it. They know that, for example, there's going to be a big service at the Orthodox Church in Sarajevo. There's always an annual remembrance service for Serbian patriots
那一刻对塞尔维亚人来说具有近乎神秘的意义。汤姆，当然，直到今天它仍然具有重要意义，这就是为什么科索沃在21世纪仍然是一个如此热门的问题。没错。所以它具有极大的煽动性。有没有人建议过皇储，也许这并不是坐敞篷车穿过萨拉热窝街道的最佳日子？人们讨论过。他们谈论过。他们知道，例如，萨拉热窝的东正教教堂将举行大型仪式。每年都有为塞尔维亚爱国者举行的纪念仪式。
who fell at the Battle of Kosovo in 1389. And because this year, St. Vitus' Day, is a Sunday and a holiday, obviously, people aren't at work, there will be more people than ever before. The Austrians know this. The authorities know it. But the army maneuvers that he's coming to watch have been scheduled for a couple of days beforehand. They can't be shifted.
那些在1389年科索沃战役中阵亡的人。而且因为今年圣维特日是星期天，也是个假日，显然人们不用上班，所以会有比以往任何时候都多的人。奥地利人知道这一点。当局也知道。但他要来观看的军事演习是在几天前就安排好的。它们无法更改。
Plus, if it goes well, which they think it will, it's a great symbol of how settled and stable things are under the Habsburg Empire. The secret police, by the way, had said it's a bad idea. But of course, as we talked about last time, Franz Ferdinand is a very stubborn man. And he has specifically said, I do not want to live under a glass jar. I, you know, will not be followed by security all my life. I want to live freely and just take the risk and trust in God. Yeah. He's kind of upholding the idea of the continuity and stability of the empire in Sarajevo.
另外，如果一切顺利，他们认为会很顺利，这将是哈布斯堡帝国统治下局势稳定、安定的伟大象征。顺便说一句，秘密警察曾说这是一个坏主意。但当然，正如我们上次谈到的，弗朗茨·斐迪南是一个非常固执的人。他明确表示过，我不想生活在玻璃罩下。我，你知道，不会一辈子都被安保人员跟踪。我想自由地生活，承担风险，并相信上帝。是的。他是在萨拉热窝维护帝国连续性和稳定性的理念。
On that note, we should just mention that we are in a symbol of Habsburg civilization in Sarajevo, namely a Viennese cafe. We are indeed. The heart of the city. At the Hotel Europa, exactly. Where we were for our last episode. Tom, you finished your cake? I have finished my cake. I'm feeling a bit ill.
说到这里，我们应该提一下，我们现在正身处萨拉热窝哈布斯堡文明的象征中，即一家维也纳咖啡馆。我们确实是在这里。城市的中心。在欧洲酒店，没错。我们上次录制节目时就在这里。汤姆，你的蛋糕吃完了吗？我吃完了。我感觉有点不舒服。
I'm not going to lie. Stupidly wolfed the whole lot down. But if you hear the steaming of coffee machines in the background, the chinking of plates, that's what's going on. So Franz Ferdinand is well aware that he may not get a universally ecstatic reception. And actually on his journey down the coast, which we talked about at the end of the last episode, he has actually tried to learn some Serbo-Croat.
我不撒谎。愚蠢地把整块都狼吞虎咽下去了。但如果你听到背景里咖啡机的蒸汽声、盘子的碰撞声，那就是正在发生的事情。所以弗朗茨·斐迪南很清楚，他可能不会得到普遍狂热的欢迎。事实上，在他沿海岸南下的旅途中，我们在上一集结尾谈到过，他实际上尝试学习了一些塞尔维亚-克罗地亚语。
He has learned some sentences. And actually, when he comes inland through Herzegovina and then into Bosnia proper, he smiles and he waves at people and he uses the phrases he's learned. Like you, Dominic. Just like me, Tom. Yeah, the parallels are uncanny.
他学了一些句子。事实上，当他穿过黑塞哥维那，然后进入波斯尼亚本土时，他微笑着向人们挥手，并使用他学到的短语。就像你一样，多米尼克。就像我一样，汤姆。是的，这种相似之处真是不可思议。
He says to people, you know, how do you do? I'm very pleased to be here. What a lovely day it is. And actually, of course, a lot of people are really surprised that he's bothered and he is delighted by his reception he was reportedly exhilarated by the time on the 25th of june he arrives in the spa town of elidja above where we are now in the hills and he arrives and there's a crowd there it's pouring with rain
他对人们说，你知道，你好吗？我很高兴来到这里。今天真是美好的一天。事实上，当然，很多人真的很惊讶他会费心这样做，而且他对受到的欢迎感到高兴。据报道，到6月25日，他抵达了我们现在所在山上的温泉小镇伊利扎时，他感到非常振奋。他到达时，那里聚集了人群，而且下着倾盆大雨。
that he's in very good spirits people are waving umbrellas and cheering. They're shouting zivio, which is kind of long life, long may you live. And he uses all his phrases again. Yeah, like you. And Sophie is there. She's already arrived by train. They stay in the best hotel, probably the best hotel in Bosnia, frankly. And they've built him a private chapel, haven't they? They have done.
他精神状态非常好，人们挥舞着雨伞欢呼。他们高喊“Zivio”，这是一种长寿、祝你长寿的意思。他又用了他所有的短语。是的，就像你一样。索菲也在那里。她已经乘火车到达了。他们住在最好的酒店，坦率地说，可能是波斯尼亚最好的酒店。他们还为他建了一个私人礼拜堂，不是吗？他们确实建了。
So the Hotel Bosna had been built as a spa resort by the austrians in elidja it has been refurbished they have built him a special apartment so you can go for a massage and have a mass massage and a mass very nice everything happens very good one everything happens very good once so the next day is the first day of the military maneuvers and that goes really really well they have 22 000. That's about half the total Austrian troop strength in Bosnia. It's raining, but it all goes really well. Franz Ferdinand has lightened the packs. He's given the orders, actually, that the backpacks of all the soldiers
所以波斯尼亚酒店是奥地利人在伊利扎建造的温泉度假村，经过了翻新，他们为他建造了一个特别的公寓，所以你可以去按摩，享受按摩，非常棒，一切都进行得非常顺利。所以第二天是军事演习的第一天，进行得非常非常顺利。他们有22000人。这大约是奥地利在波斯尼亚总兵力的一半。虽然下着雨，但一切都很顺利。弗朗茨·斐迪南减轻了负重。他实际上下了命令，所有士兵的背包。
should be lighter than they otherwise would be because he wants them to have a good time. And that all goes well. He's very impressed. He's a party animal beneath the walrus exterior. He's making great jokes. So there's a man lurking in the bushes who leaps out of the bushes holding what looks like a gun.
应该比平时更轻，因为他希望他们能玩得开心。一切都很顺利。他印象非常深刻。在海象般的外表下，他其实是个派对动物。他讲着很棒的笑话。这时，灌木丛中潜伏着一个人，他跳了出来，手里拿着看起来像枪的东西。
And the bodyguards rush to intercept this bloke. And Franz Fenner says, no, look at him. He's a photographer. Let him shoot me. Yeah. That's his job. He's a cult photographer. Everybody thinks, what a japester what a great joke at the end of
保镖们冲上去拦截这个家伙。弗朗茨·斐迪南说，不，看看他。他是摄影师。让他拍我吧。是的。那是他的工作。他是位邪教摄影师。每个人都想，真是个爱开玩笑的人，真是个好笑话。在第一天结束时。
the first day he and sophie do something very sweet actually they get a car and they make an impromptu visit they drive down the hill into the city because she wants to go and buy a carpet she has heard about the bazaar some we were So we've been walking through the bazaar quarter, which is probably pretty unchanged. I mean, obviously now it's full of souvenir shops, but there's mosques, there's an old caravanserai. It feels like a little bit of Turkey. And they had gone with no security and it had been great.
他和索菲做了一件非常甜蜜的事情，实际上他们找了一辆车，进行了一次即兴访问，他们开车下山进入城市，因为她想去买地毯，她听说过集市。所以我们走过了集市区域，这里可能基本没变。我的意思是，显然现在到处都是纪念品商店，但这里有清真寺，有一个古老的商队旅馆。感觉有点像土耳其。他们没有带安保人员，而且玩得很开心。
The crowds, people had rushed around them been delighted to see them you know people are very excited uh that the archduke the heir to the throne his wife have come they'd had an absolutely brilliant time the next day is the second day of the maneuvers saturday the 27th of june that day goes really well as as well and franz ferdinand actually sends a telegram to the emperor he says my journey has been excellent the reception very gratifying and patriotic the condition of the soldiers and their performance were outstanding and really beyond praise because he's genuinely quite impressed isn't he by their performance he thinks everybody says our army is
人群，人们围着他们，很高兴见到他们，你知道，人们非常兴奋，皇储、王位继承人、他的妻子来了，他们度过了一段非常美好的时光。第二天是演习的第二天，6月27日星期六。那天也进行得非常顺利，弗朗茨·斐迪南实际上给皇帝发了一封电报，他说我的旅程非常出色，接待非常令人欣慰和爱国，士兵们的情况和他们的表现非常出色，确实无可挑剔，因为他确实对他们的表现印象深刻，不是吗？他认为每个人都说我们的军队是。
terrible actually they've done pretty well now to, to be honest, Tom, when the First World War starts, the Austrians do not cover themselves with glory, no. But he says, you know, all is good. Tomorrow I'm going to go to Sarajevo. In the evening, I'll come back. Everything's been great. I'll see you when I get back. And he has his words of commendation.
糟糕的，实际上他们表现得相当不错。现在，说实话，汤姆，当第一次世界大战开始时，奥地利人并没有赢得荣耀，没有。但他确实说，你知道，一切都很好。明天我要去萨拉热窝。晚上我会回来。一切都很棒。我回来后再见。他有他的嘉奖词。
You said in the previous podcast, he's regarded as a very rude man, which often he is. But he has this read by every regimental commander in the previous podcast he's regarded as a very rude man which often he is but he has this read by every regimental commander in the language of each regiment to be read out to the soldiers and they're delighted the governor of bosnia general potty orick he is delighted everything is they have a banquet that evening strauss waltz's fine wines all of this stuff it's great it's everything that um the hapsburg Empire should be at its best. Now, that evening, some people say,
你在上一期播客中说，他被认为是一个非常粗鲁的人，他确实经常这样。但他让每个团长用每个团的语言读出这些话，读给士兵们听，他们很高兴。波斯尼亚总督波蒂奥雷克将军，他很高兴，一切都很好。那天晚上他们举行了宴会，施特劳斯的圆舞曲，美酒，所有这些东西，太棒了，这就是哈布斯堡帝国处于最佳状态时应该有的样子。现在，那天晚上，有些人说。
listen, this has been great. Let's not push our luck. One of his flunkies is a guy called Baron von Rummerskirch, says to him, why don't we just bin the rest of the trip? Go back to the coast. The Dreadnought is still there. Why don't you go up to Trieste with Sophie? You can have your wedding anniversary there on the first of july it'll be brilliant and one reason he says that
听着，这已经很棒了。我们不要冒险了。他的一个随从是一个叫冯·鲁默斯基希男爵的人，对他说，为什么我们不取消剩下的行程？回海岸去吧。无畏舰还在那里。为什么你不和索菲一起去的里雅斯特？你可以在7月1日那里庆祝你们的结婚纪念日，那会很棒。他这么说的一个原因是。
is a bosnian croat leader dr sunaric has been talking to sophie the night before and sophie had said we've been to the bazaar and we had great fun you know everyone was really nice they were really kind to us and there's no problems here at all and dr sunarich had said to sophie listen i pray to god that you say that tomorrow evening because i'm being really worried about it when i see you go safe and sound a great burden will be lifted from me and all this so when they have this conversation the governor's adjutant who's a guy called lieutenant colonel von merizzi we'll hear about him a little bit later he says what you can't scrap the plan you know that would look really bad there are loads of
波斯尼亚克罗地亚领导人苏纳里奇博士前一天晚上和索菲谈过，索菲说我们去了集市，玩得很开心，你知道，每个人都很好，他们对我们真的很友善，这里根本没有问题。苏纳里奇博士对索菲说，听着，我向上帝祈祷你明天晚上也能这么说，因为我真的很担心。当我看到你们平安无事时，我心中的大石头就会落地。所以当他们进行这次谈话时，总督的副官，一个叫冯·梅里齐中校的人，我们稍后会听到关于他的消息，他说，你不能取消计划，你知道，那看起来会很糟糕，城里有很多。
hapsburg loyalists in the city who cannot wait to see you tomorrow it would be insulting for the governor just go through the plan and there won't be any problems at all it'll be fine it'll be fine nothing will happen and as the historian thomas otty says with that decision began the end of austria hungary so it's the 28th of june this is sunday yes it's the anniversary of the battle of kosovo and it's the anniversary of franz ferdinand making the decision renunciation all that kind of thing yeah and sun rises over the hills that surrounds sarajevo yeah and the arch the Archduke and the Duchess are in their private chapel, aren't they? They do. They start the day with Mass,
哈布斯堡的忠诚者迫不及待地想明天见到你，这对总督来说将是一种侮辱，只要按计划进行，就不会有任何问题，一切都会好的，一切都会好的，什么都不会发生。正如历史学家托马斯·奥蒂所说，随着那个决定，奥匈帝国的终结开始了。所以今天是6月28日，这是星期天，是的，这是科索沃战役的周年纪念日，也是弗朗茨·斐迪南做出放弃继承权决定等等的周年纪念日。是的，太阳升起在萨拉热窝周围的山丘上，是的，皇储和公爵夫人在他们的私人礼拜堂里，不是吗？他们确实去了。他们以弥撒开始这一天。
and then they go back to their apartment, to the room. Franz Ferdinand is practicing again his phrases. He has a paragraph at the end of the speech he's going to give. He's going to go to the city hall and make a speech, and he wants to end it with his phrases. With his phrases and a little serbo-croate. A double room with a shower three beers please exactly help i've been mugged here is my travel insurance number oh dear my cart has fallen to its doom he's got this paragraph and he's going to end and he's practicing and practicing and practicing when he's finished doing this he comes
然后他们回到他们的公寓，回到房间。弗朗茨·斐迪南又在练习他的短语。他要在演讲结束时加一段话。他要去市政厅发表演讲，他想用他的短语结束演讲。用他的短语和一点塞尔维亚-克罗地亚语。一个带淋浴的双人间，请给我三杯啤酒，救命，我被抢劫了，这是我的旅行保险号码，哦天哪，我的车掉进深渊了。他有这段话，他正在练习，练习，练习。当他做完这些后，他出来。
out and sophie says i've had brilliant news we've just had a message from vienna max their oldest son who is i think about 11 he's just had his exam results from the shotten academy and he's done really really well it's all too poignant so they send max a telegram then and there well done son we'll see you tomorrow can't wait to see you we can celebrate properly so it is very sad tom actually isn't it so by then it's about um about nine o'clock nine o'clock they're going to take the train it's only going to be a 20 minute ride or so the train a special court train again very like kennedy going from um fort worth to dallas yeah exactly just a short hop and almost unnecessarily short hop so they get the train down to the station in Sarajevo now to remind people Sarajevo runs from west to east along a
索菲说，我有个好消息，我们刚收到维也纳的消息，马克斯，我们最大的儿子，我想大约11岁，他刚拿到了肖滕学院的考试成绩，他考得非常好。这一切都太令人心酸了。所以他们当场就给马克斯发了电报，干得好，儿子，我们明天见，迫不及待想见到你，我们可以好好庆祝一下。所以这真的很悲伤，汤姆，不是吗？所以到那时大约是九点钟，九点钟，他们要乘火车，只需要20分钟左右的车程，火车，一列特别的宫廷列车，又非常像肯尼迪从沃斯堡到达拉斯，是的，完全一样，只是一个短途旅行，而且是不必要的短途旅行。所以他们乘火车到了萨拉热窝车站。现在提醒一下，萨拉热窝从西向东沿着一个。
sort of very narrow valley with a river in the middle the Milyatska and that river has been straightened out by Habsburg engineers it has indeed there's a road running alongside it and the station is at the left-hand end, so the west end, and they're going to be heading to the right, to the east. They're in all their fineries, so anybody who has ever seen the photos will know what I'm talking about.
非常狭窄的山谷，中间有一条河，米利亚茨卡河，那条河已经被哈布斯堡的工程师拉直了。确实如此，有一条路沿着它延伸，车站位于左端，也就是西端，他们将向右，向东前进。他们穿着盛装，所以任何看过照片的人都会知道我在说什么。
The Archduke is wearing this sort of sky blue military uniform, into which he's sort of been crammed, hasn't he? Yeah, stuffed. Stuffed. Yeah. Like a kind of sausage. Yeah, absolutely. He's got a gold crammed, hasn't he? Yes, stuffed. Yeah, like a kind of sausage. Yeah, absolutely.
皇储穿着这种天蓝色的军装，他被塞进去了，不是吗？是的，塞进去了。塞进去了。是的。像一种香肠。是的，绝对是。他有一个金色的。
He's got a gold collar, very tight collar. He's got his hat with his green ostrich feathers. An absolutely magnificent hat with these green sort of feathers. I don't know if he'd shot the bird himself. I imagine not. There aren't many ostriches in Vienna, are there? No. And Sophie is wearing all white.
他有一个金色的领子，非常紧的领子。他戴着有绿色鸵鸟毛的帽子。一顶绝对华丽的帽子，上面有这些绿色的羽毛。我不知道他是不是自己射杀了那只鸟。我想不是。维也纳没有多少鸵鸟，对吧？没有。索菲穿着全白色的衣服。
She has the most enormous hat, doesn't she? She's got a splendid hat with a white veil. If you think Edwardian summer, what was it like in June 1914? That's the image that comes into my mind. Shimmering, upper-class woman in white dress. Exactly. So they get into their car. So the motorcade has six cars.
她戴着一顶巨大的帽子，不是吗？她戴着一顶华丽的帽子，上面有白色的面纱。如果你想到爱德华时代的夏天，1914年6月是什么样的？这就是我脑海中浮现的形象。闪闪发光的、穿着白色连衣裙的上流社会女性。没错。所以他们上了车。所以车队有六辆车。
It's often thought they're in the first car they are not they're in actually depending which account you read either the second or the third i think it's pretty clear they're in the third the first car is a car for plainclothes detectives and police some of whom have already been left behind in a kind of confusion there's an air of slight confusion and shambles about this which I think actually probably is standard and not very surprising. It's an age, you know, when communications are difficult. Yeah, no one's got texts. No, they can't text each other and say when they're setting off.
人们常以为他们在第一辆车里，其实不是，根据你读到的不同记录，他们实际上是在第二辆或第三辆，我认为很清楚他们在第三辆。第一辆车是给便衣侦探和警察坐的，其中一些人已经在混乱中被落下了。这其中有一种轻微的混乱和混乱的气氛，我认为这实际上可能是常态，并不令人惊讶。这是一个你知道，通讯困难的时代。是的，没有人有短信。不，他们不能互相发短信说他们什么时候出发。
So they have to leave some people behind. The second car has the mayor of Sarajevo, who is a Bosnian Muslim. He is called Fehim Efendi Čurčić. He's got his fez on and his official sash. And the chief of police, who is called Dr. Gerda. And then you've got the third car, the Archdukel car that you can see right to this day in the museum in Vienna, made by Griff and Stift.
所以他们不得不留下一些人。第二辆车里有萨拉热窝市长，他是一位波斯尼亚穆斯林。他叫费希姆·埃芬迪·丘尔契奇。他戴着土耳其毡帽，系着官方腰带。还有警察局长，他叫格尔达博士。然后是第三辆车，皇储的车，你今天在维也纳的博物馆里还能看到，由格拉夫和斯蒂夫制造。
And this is flying the imperial flag, yellow and black Habsburg flag. The chauffeur is a Czech. He's called Leopold Sojka. And also with him in the front is the guy who owns the car who is count franz harak i get the impression he's a kind of friend of franz fernand or kind of general hanger on in that kind of world then you have behind them in the jump seat governor potty orick now regular listeners will know there's only one context in which you ever
这辆车上飘扬着帝国旗帜，黄黑色的哈布斯堡旗帜。司机是个捷克人。他叫利奥波德·索伊卡。和他坐在前排的还有这辆车的主人，弗朗茨·哈拉赫伯爵。我感觉他是弗朗茨·斐迪南的朋友，或者说是那个世界里的随从。然后他们后面是坐在跳板座上的总督波蒂奥雷克。现在，经常收听节目的听众会知道，只有一种情况下你才会。
mention a jump seat in a car and that is somebody is being assassinated assassinated so in 1963 it was governor john connolly of texas and on this occasion it is uh it's a lesson of history isn't it if you're a governor yeah and you're going on an open motorcade through a city. Don't sit in the jump seat. Jump seat spells doom, Tom. And on that note, did you see the number plate of the car? Go on. So it's A111118. Right.
提到车里的跳板座，那就是有人被暗杀了。所以1963年是德克萨斯州州长约翰·康纳利，而这次是，这是一个历史教训，不是吗？如果你是州长，是的，你要坐敞篷车穿过城市。不要坐在跳板座上。跳板座意味着厄运，汤姆。说到这里，你看到那辆车的车牌了吗？说吧。是A111118。没错。
The war finished on the 11th of the 11th 18. What are the chances? What are the chances? It's all part of the conspiracy, right? Very eerie. Yeah. So then you've got the Archduke and Sophieie in the back of this eerily number plated car so remember there is very little security and that is by design general pottyorek has given explicit instructions the army must not enter the city and they've been told it doesn't want to look like an occupying
战争在18年11月11日结束。这概率是多少？这概率是多少？这都是阴谋的一部分，对吧？非常诡异。是的。所以皇储和索菲坐在那辆车牌诡异的车后座上。所以记住，几乎没有安保，这是故意的。波蒂奥雷克将军明确指示，军队不得进入城市，他们被告知不想看起来像占领。
power no if they enter the city they'll be in been told... Because it doesn't want to look like an occupying power. No. If they enter the city, they'll be in the deepest of trouble. Police only. And there's only 120 police in Sarajevo. And we must keep security as light as possible so that people can see the royal couple. So they set off. Then a bit which has actually left out of most accounts.
力量，不，如果他们进入城市，他们会陷入……因为不想看起来像占领力量。不。如果他们进入城市，他们会陷入极大的麻烦。只能是警察。萨拉热窝只有120名警察。我们必须保持安保尽可能轻，以便人们能看到皇室夫妇。所以他们出发了。然后是一段实际上被大多数记录遗漏的部分。
But it's very touching. They stop at the military barracks first it has been raining but the sun has come out and sophie has this big parasol he carries it for her doesn't he he does so he's like her servitor her her knight and this is against all protocol in all the court protocol of course remember she was not allowed to be next to him. She had to be way behind him. On this occasion, they walk together to inspect the troops. He holds her parasol for her. And as one of the writers, I can't remember which one it is, says, today, instead of denying her existence, he celebrated it.
但这非常感人。他们先在军营停了下来，天一直在下雨，但太阳出来了，索菲拿着这把大遮阳伞，他为她拿着，不是吗？他确实拿着。所以他就像她的仆人，她的骑士，这违反了所有的礼仪，在所有的宫廷礼仪中，当然，记住她不允许站在他旁边。她必须在他后面很远。这次，他们一起走去视察部队。他为她拿着遮阳伞。正如其中一位作家，我不记得是哪一位了，说，今天，他没有否认她的存在，而是赞美了它。
He exalted it. He, crown prince of the realm, was her servitor. He carried her parasol at the most public occasion so it's quite a poignant so he had that moment of happiness exactly they get back in their cars cannons are now booming um in honor of the visit from the kind of the fortress above the city they set off along the apple key along the river embankment so this is the broad road yes built by the engineers along the straightened river. They are driving deliberately slowly
他赞美了它。他，王国的王储，是她的仆人。他在最公开的场合为她拿着遮阳伞，所以这非常令人心酸。所以他有过那一刻的幸福。没错，他们回到车里，大炮现在在轰鸣，以纪念这次访问，从城市上方的堡垒传来。他们沿着阿佩尔码头，沿着河堤出发。所以这是一条宽阔的道路，是的，由工程师沿着拉直的河流建造。他们故意开得很慢。
because they want people to see them and because they want to see the city. They want to look. Sarajevo is famous within the Habsburg Empire. It has mosques. It has Catholic churches. It has Orthodox churches. Virtually nowhere else has this mix has this mix and they
因为他们想让人们看到他们，也因为他们想看这座城市。他们想看看。萨拉热窝在哈布斯堡帝国境内很有名。它有清真寺。它有天主教堂。它有东正教堂。几乎没有其他地方有这种混合，有这种混合，而且他们。
want to see it so they're going very slowly along the river there are quite big crowds people are flying imperial flags in the windows there are shops have been told to put pictures of the archduke up in the shops there are lots of flowers and as far as we know there was no reason to doubt it the reaction is very warm people are shouting jivio hurrah long live the archduke great stuff love it all seems to be going brilliantly what could possibly go wrong well we said the cannons were booming the cannons are booming booming booming and then there's another boom that is not a cannon and everybody is horrified well some of them think it's a kind of tire blowing, don't they? Or the engine backfiring or something like that.
想看看它，所以他们沿着河边开得很慢，人群相当大，人们在窗户上飘扬着帝国旗帜，商店被告知要在店里挂上皇储的照片，有很多鲜花，据我们所知，没有理由怀疑这一点，反应非常热烈，人们高喊“Zivio”，万岁，皇储万岁，太棒了，喜欢这一切，似乎一切都进行得非常顺利，什么可能出错呢？好吧，我们说过大炮在轰鸣，大炮在轰鸣，轰鸣，轰鸣，然后还有一声轰鸣，那不是大炮，每个人都感到震惊。好吧，有些人以为是轮胎爆了，不是吗？或者引擎回火之类的。
And there's suddenly a sense of confusion for the people watching. Something is happening around the Archduke's car. Sophie is reaching to the back of her neck. She's felt a kind of little sting like an insect or something has bitten her. And suddenly people are running along the quayside. The Archduke's car stops. Count von Harrach, who is in the front, jumps out. And what has happened is somebody has thrown a bomb. It has almost certainly hit the back of their car, hit the kind of canopy which has been lowered,
观看的人群中突然出现了一种混乱感。皇储的车周围发生了什么事。索菲正伸手摸她的后颈。她感觉到一种像昆虫或什么东西咬了她一下的刺痛。突然人们沿着码头奔跑。皇储的车停了下来。坐在前排的冯·哈拉赫伯爵跳了出来。发生的事情是有人扔了一枚炸弹。它几乎肯定击中了他们车的后部，击中了已经放下的顶篷。
bounced off and exploded under the car behind them. Now, in the car behind them was that guy, Lieutenant Colonel von Maritzi, who had had said you cannot cancel under any circumstances he has been wounded he has been hit in the head and blood is pouring out of his head sophie says oh it must have been a splinter or a bit of shrapnel or something that just nicked me on the back of my neck franz ferninand looks at the back of her neck. It was just a little scratch. And, you know, the smoke from the car behind. And the amazing thing about this is a bomb has been thrown at them. It has hit the car behind them out of six cars.
弹开并在他们后面的车下爆炸了。现在，在他们后面的车里是那个家伙，冯·梅里齐中校，他曾说无论如何都不能取消，他受伤了，他的头部被击中，血从他头上流出来。索菲说，哦，那一定是一块碎片或弹片之类的东西，只是擦伤了我的后颈。弗朗茨·斐迪南看着她的后颈。那只是一个小划痕。而且，你知道，后面车里的烟。这件事最令人惊奇的是，有人向他们扔了一枚炸弹。它击中了六辆车中后面的那辆。
And Franz Ferdinand says, that fellow must have been mad. Let's carry on. It's a tremendous sans-foi. And this always amazes me throughout this whole story a bomb has been thrown at them and it's gone off and hit the car behind and one of the party has been injured and there was smoke and there was chaos and he just says well we'll carry on with the day that's not you know a lot of people i mean frankly tom would you and i if the rest is history tour if a bomb was thrown oh i'd be a gibbering wreck would we continue no i'd be an absolute gibbering wreck i mean i wouldn't have done it in the first place i'm not gonna lie if you heard that there was there was
弗朗茨·斐迪南说，那个家伙一定是疯了。我们继续吧。这是一种巨大的冷静。在整个故事中，这总是让我感到惊讶，一枚炸弹向他们扔去，它爆炸并击中了后面的车，其中一名随行人员受伤了，有烟雾，有混乱，而他只是说，好吧，我们将继续这一天，那不是，你知道，很多人，坦率地说，汤姆，如果“历史的余味”巡演时扔了一枚炸弹，哦，我会是一个语无伦次的残骸，我们会继续吗？不，我会是一个绝对语无伦次的残骸，我的意思是，我一开始就不会那样做，我不撒谎，如果你听说有。
possibility of bombings yeah i would have said that's the difference but then i lacked i lack a sense of duty right well anyway they continue on count von Harach does not get into the front. He stands on the kind of running board of the car to shield the Archduke if there are more assassins. So they continue. Now, there's somebody we have not mentioned at all who sees this happening or realizes that something has happened. And is that Gavrilo?
炸弹袭击的可能性，是的，我会说这就是区别，但我缺乏责任感，对吧？好吧，无论如何，他们继续前进。冯·哈拉赫伯爵没有坐到前排。他站在车的踏板上，如果还有刺客，就保护皇储。所以他们继续前进。现在，有一个我们根本没有提到的人看到了这一切发生，或者意识到发生了什么。那是加夫里洛吗？
And that is Gavrilo Princip. So people may remember that we left him on the night before the assassination. He's gone to the grave of this guy who had attempted to assassinate the governor. He'd had five shots, missed all of them, and then shot himself. That's right. And he's a kind of great inspiration to Princip and to the other five assassins who are part of these cells that are ready to do the assassination.
那是加夫里洛·普林西普。所以人们可能记得我们把他在暗杀前一天晚上留下了。他去了那个试图暗杀总督的家伙的墓前。他开了五枪，全部打偏，然后自杀了。没错。他是普林西普和其他五个刺客的伟大灵感来源，他们是准备进行暗杀的组织的一部分。
And they had agreed, we'll meet at the pastry shop tomorrow at eight. We'll split up and we'll assassins who are part of these these cells that are yeah ready to do the assassination and they had agreed we'll meet at the pastry shop tomorrow eight we'll split up and we'll take positions along the street and this is exactly what they had done so gavrilo princip had been waiting there in position since nine o'clock he'd waited in the crowd he had his bomb in his pocket he had his capsule of cyanide he had his pistol just after 10 o'clock he had heard the crowd cheering he had heard the sound of the car engines he had seen in the distance the car advancing then he'd heard the bomb explosion like so many other people he runs towards the scene and actually what he sees is the guy who was the blabbermouth the guy he'd always doubted yeah so the guy who was sending um
他们已经商定，明天八点在糕点店见面。我们将分开，我们将刺客，他们是这些组织的一部分，是的，准备进行暗杀，他们已经商定，明天八点在糕点店见面，我们将分开，我们将沿着街道占据位置，这正是他们所做的。所以加夫里洛·普林西普从九点钟开始就一直在那里等待。他在人群中等待，口袋里有炸弹。他有氰化物胶囊，他有手枪。刚过十点，他听到了人群的欢呼声。他听到了汽车引擎的声音。他在远处看到了汽车前进，然后他听到了炸弹爆炸。像许多其他人一样，他跑向现场，实际上他看到的是那个大嘴巴的家伙，他一直怀疑的那个家伙，是的，所以那个发送。
inappropriate postcards into the uh austro-hungarian empire nedeliko chabrinovich he has thrown his bomb now the first two people the first two assassins totally bottled it muhammad mehmed bazich and vaso chabrinovich they did nothing and afterwards at the trial they said oh i uh the time wasn't quite right i actually didn't feel like you know they just flunked it i mean it's a big deal isn't it because basically you you may well be killing yourself yeah well you are but the plan is you will kill yourself chabrinovich did throw his bomb as we said it hit the back of the car exploded onto the car behind there are some accounts there are some um televised versions of which the archery
不恰当的明信片到奥匈帝国的内德利科·查布里诺维奇，他扔了他的炸弹。现在，前两个人，前两个刺客完全退缩了，穆罕默德·梅赫梅德·巴兹奇和瓦索·查布里诺维奇，他们什么也没做。事后在审判中他们说，哦，我，时间不太对，我实际上并不觉得，你知道，他们只是搞砸了。我的意思是，这是一件大事，不是吗？因为基本上你很可能会自杀。是的，你是，但计划是你将自杀。查布里诺维奇确实扔了他的炸弹，正如我们所说，它击中了车的后部，在后面的车上爆炸了。有一些记录，有一些电视版本，其中皇储。
catches it and throws it it's kind of cricketer like a cricketer there's a brilliant christopher plumber film which is like a slip fielder kind of taking a catch or something this did not happen i think i think what happened is it bounced off but what had happened then was that chabrinovich took his cyanide well no he and he jumped over there so a twin attempt to commit suicide yes and they're both disastrous yes because actually when i read about this i thought i imagined the the drop being quite extensive into the river into the river but it's not it's it's not very far and the river is very shallow yeah the prospect of killing yourself by throwing yourself into the river is is minimal yeah but he does have his cyanide doesn't he and he bites on that yeah but it the power has faded and it just kind of gives him a sore throat yeah never put
接住了它并扔了出去，这就像板球运动员，像板球运动员一样，有一部精彩的克里斯托弗·普卢默电影，就像滑球手接球一样，这并没有发生。我想，我想发生的是它弹开了，但随后发生的是查布里诺维奇服用了他的氰化物，好吧，不，他跳了过去，所以是一次双重自杀尝试，是的，而且都非常灾难性，是的，因为实际上当我读到这个时，我想象掉进河里的落差相当大，但并不是，它离得不远，而且河水非常浅，是的，通过跳进河里自杀的前景微乎其微，是的，但他确实有他的氰化物，不是吗？他咬了它，是的，但药效已经减弱了，它只是让他喉咙痛，永远不要把。
your trust in serbian cyanide tom is the lesson of this podcast because the cyanide is degraded it just basically burns his throat incredibly badly but does not kill him okay so a bit more than a sore throat i'm being unfair he falls into this river but doesn't you know he's up to his kind of his knees or something then he's sort of wading and trying to get out loads of men pile drag him onto the bank a barber almost has to be restrained from shooting him you know it's just general chaos and whatnot and princip his initial reaction was i will go and kill him you know i stop him talking and then he think he gets there and he thinks that's mad actually you know there's a huge crowd i can't shoot him and then he looks for his fellow assassins and in the chaos they've vanished they've all scarpered they've all lost their nerve and he alone is
你的信任放在塞尔维亚氰化物上，汤姆，这是这期播客的教训，因为氰化物已经降解了，它基本上只是烧伤了他的喉咙，非常严重，但没有杀死他。好吧，比喉咙痛严重一点，我有点不公平。他掉进了河里，但没有，你知道，水深到他的膝盖左右，然后他涉水试图爬出来，很多人冲上去把他拖到岸上，一个理发师差点被拦住才没开枪打死他，你知道，这只是普遍的混乱等等。普林西普最初的反应是，我要去杀了他，你知道，我让他闭嘴，然后他想，他到了那里，他想那太疯狂了，实际上，你知道，有很多人，我不能开枪打他，然后他寻找他的刺客同伙，在混乱中他们消失了。他们都逃跑了，他们都失去了勇气，而他独自一人。
standing there he's got his bomb he's got his pistol and meanwhile of course in the distance the archduke has driven off towards city hall the archduke has said let's continue the visit so princip is just standing there he does not know what to do he thinks well it's all failed it's failed but maybe the only thing i can hope is that um maybe they'll come back the same way maybe they'll come back and he goes he crosses the road and he goes to the corner of a delicatessen run by a guy called Moritz Schiller. And there he just stands there at a loss, waiting, hoping against hope
站在那里，他有炸弹，他有手枪，与此同时，当然，在远处，皇储已经开车前往市政厅。皇储说，让我们继续访问。所以普林西普只是站在那里，他不知道该怎么办。他想，好吧，一切都失败了，失败了，但也许我唯一能希望的是，也许他们会原路返回，也许他们会回来。他穿过马路，走到一家由莫里茨·席勒经营的熟食店拐角处。在那里，他只是站在那里，不知所措，等待着，怀着一线希望。
that he will get another chance. And when we come back, we will find out if he does get that chance. But meanwhile, the Archduke and Sophie are heading off towards the City Hall. And Dominic, in the interval, I think that's where we should head. So we should leave our Viennese cafe and go to the City Hall
他会得到另一个机会。当我们回来时，我们将找出他是否得到了那个机会。但与此同时，皇储和索菲正前往市政厅。多米尼克，在中间休息时，我想我们应该去那里。所以我们应该离开我们的维也纳咖啡馆，去市政厅。
and see what happened there when the Archduke arrives. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
看看皇储到达那里时发生了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We are in Sarajevo, and Dominic, we've now for the first time come out on the streets. And on one side of us, we have the city hall of Sarajevo, where around 10.15 on the morning of the 28th of June 1914, the Archduke of Motocade arrived. It's described in the notes that you've written up as a massive pseudo-Moorish monstrosity.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们在萨拉热窝，多米尼克，我们现在第一次走上街头。在我们的一侧，是萨拉热窝市政厅，1914年6月28日上午10点15分左右，皇储的车队到达了那里。在你写的笔记中，它被描述为一个巨大的伪摩尔式怪物。
And that is exactly what it is. It's an extraordinary building. So it's got the kind of the color scheme that you get in the court of a mosque. It's got lots of kind of lattice work. It's got a few kind of Corinthian pillars as well. It's a very odd building, but definitely kind of Austro- It's got a few kind of Corinthian pillars as well. It's a very odd building, but definitely kind of Austro-Hungarian. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely got that kind of vibe. But what's amazing is you look down on the right-hand side where we're sitting, back into
这正是它的样子。这是一座非凡的建筑。它有你在清真寺庭院里看到的那种配色方案。它有很多格子装饰。它还有一些科林斯柱。这是一座非常奇怪的建筑，但绝对是奥匈帝国的。是的，绝对是。绝对有那种氛围。但令人惊奇的是，你向下看我们坐的右侧，回到。
the bazaar, and you've got those two extraordinary domes of the mosques that Arthur Evans described as being a cause of wonder to peasants coming in from the Bosnian hills. And talking of Bosnian hills, I mean, you can see them right in front of us, the extent to which Sarajevo is at the bottom of a great bowl. And although we're not talking about the civil war in the 90s, I mean, it's kind of chilling to imagine guns up there and firing down. But we're looking at another tragedy today. And Dominic, that, of course, is the shooting that starts effectively the First World War. Yeah.
集市，还有那两座非凡的清真寺圆顶，亚瑟·埃文斯曾描述说，它们让从波斯尼亚山丘赶来的农民们感到惊叹。说到波斯尼亚的山丘，我的意思是，你可以直接看到它们就在我们面前，萨拉热窝坐落在一个巨大盆地的底部。虽然我们现在谈论的不是90年代的内战，但想象一下枪支架在那里向下射击，还是让人不寒而栗。但我们今天关注的是另一场悲剧。多米尼克，那当然就是实际上引发第一次世界大战的那场枪击事件。是的。
In the first half, we heard about a bomb attack on the procession of cars. The Archduke and his wife have survived the attack. But obviously, I mean, it creates enormous sense of panic, doesn't it? And they arrive at the town hall, which is part of the plan. But obviously the schedule is, you'd think, going to be rearranged. Or is it? And you'd think that the talks that are due to be given to the Archduke also are going to be slightly rewritten.
在上半部分，我们听到了关于车队遭遇炸弹袭击的消息。大公和他的妻子在袭击中幸存了下来。但显然，这造成了巨大的恐慌，不是吗？他们抵达了市政厅，这是计划的一部分。但很明显，你可能会认为行程会被重新安排。或者会吗？你可能还会认为，原本准备给大公的演讲稿也会被稍微修改一下。
But again, are they? Very good questions, Tom. Just to give people a sense, Sarajevo is very small by the standards of european capitals so you know we have walked pretty much the route that franz ferdinand and sophie took the entire route would probably take you what half an hour 40 minutes maybe if you're walking quite slowly so as you say you know they've they've come up the road which we're looking at to the right. The motorcade has stopped. Outside the city hall,
但真的会吗？很好的问题，汤姆。为了让大家有个概念，按照欧洲首都的标准，萨拉热窝非常小，所以我们几乎走完了弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲走过的路线，整条路线如果你走得很慢，可能也就半小时到40分钟。所以正如你所说，他们沿着我们现在看到的这条路过来，在右边。车队停在了市政厅外。
so outside this extraordinary sort of multicoloured building, at the top of a sort of white marble staircase, there are all the bigwigs of the city. Well, it's a very multicultural building, isn't it? Kind of hints of the classical Victorian architecture and Moorish. Yeah. And I suppose there's a kind of quality of that in the dignitaries who are waiting to meet him
就在这座非凡的、色彩斑斓的建筑外，在白色大理石台阶的顶端，站着城里所有的显贵。嗯，这是一座非常多元文化的建筑，不是吗？带有一种古典维多利亚式建筑和摩尔风格的韵味。是的。我想那些等待迎接他的政要们身上也有某种类似的特质。
because you've got mullers in turbans, you've got bishops, you've got rabbis, you've got kind of town functionaries in sashes. Yes. Kind of melange. It is a melange. Franz Ferdinand and Sophie get out of the car. So you were saying, you know,
因为你有戴着头巾的穆拉，有主教，有拉比，还有穿着饰带的市政官员。是的。一种大杂烩。确实是大杂烩。弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲下了车。所以你刚才说，
is the visit going to continue as planned? Apparently, yes. They've arrived where they're meant to be. Sophie get out of the car. So you were saying, you know, is the visit going to continue as planned? Apparently, yes. They've arrived where they're meant to be. They get out of the car. Now, the mayor, who was in the car ahead of them, Fehm Effendi Csircic, he's wearing this costume that is very much a blend of East and West. So he's wearing a fez, but also a kind of tailcoat.
访问会按计划继续吗？显然，是的。他们已经到达了目的地。索菲下了车。所以你刚才说，访问会按计划继续吗？显然，是的。他们已经到达了目的地。他们下了车。现在，坐在他们前面那辆车里的市长费姆·埃芬迪·西尔契奇，他穿着一套非常融合东西方风格的服装。他戴着土耳其毡帽，但同时也穿着燕尾服。
Now, he has heard a bang from behind. He's aware something has gone wrong. He doesn't know what it is. But he does know he's got to deliver the welcome he's got to deliver the welcome speech he's obviously nervous so he steps forward he's described by christopher clark in the sleepwalkers as in a state of high agitation and perspiring heavily and he's too nervous to change his speech so So he says, Your Imperial and Royal Highness, our exalted Crown Prince, Your Serene Highness,
现在，他听到了身后传来一声巨响。他意识到出了问题。他不知道发生了什么。但他知道他必须发表欢迎辞，他必须发表欢迎辞。他显然很紧张，所以他走上前去。克里斯托弗·克拉克在《梦游者》中形容他处于高度焦虑状态，汗流浃背。他太紧张了，无法修改演讲稿，所以他说：“帝国和王室殿下，我们尊贵的皇储，宁静的殿下，”
our Crown Prince's most esteemed wife, at this very happy moment, all our hearts, as you can see, are overflowing with happiness and gratitude. And the Archduke, Franz Ferdinand, who's always a hot-tempered man. He loses it. He says like,
“我们皇储最受尊敬的妻子，在这个非常幸福的时刻，正如你们所见，我们所有人的心中都充满了幸福和感激。”而大公弗朗茨·斐迪南，他一直是个脾气火爆的人。他失控了。他说：
What? I've just been attacked he says what's outrageous he says somebody's just thrown a bomb at us what are you wittering about like we're all happy i mean you can see why he's crossed tom if we were doing one of our rest is history live shows or tours or something and somebody threw a bomb at you and then i went on stage and said thank you for this lovely reception yeah i would be cross you'd be You'd be cross. I'd be upset, I think. So the Archduke Franz Ferdinand. But I love this moment because he's losing it.
“什么？我刚刚遭到袭击，”他说，“这太离谱了，有人刚刚向我们扔了一枚炸弹，你在胡言乱语些什么？我们都很幸福？我的意思是，你可以看出他为什么会生气，汤姆。如果我们正在做我们的《历史的休息》现场秀或巡演之类的，有人向你扔了一枚炸弹，然后我走上台说‘谢谢你们的热情接待’，是的，我会生气的。”你会生气的。我想我会很难过的。所以大公弗朗茨·斐迪南。但我喜欢这一刻，因为他失控了。
Yes. He's threatening a diplomatic incident. And then Sophie calms him down. And it's a wonderful demonstration of the role that she has played in his life. Yeah, because she steps forward and whispers something in his ear. We don't know what it is. And he says, OK, very well, Mr. Mayor,
是的。他正在引发一场外交事件。然后索菲让他冷静了下来。这是她在他生命中所扮演角色的绝佳证明。是的，因为她走上前去，在他耳边低语了几句。我们不知道那是什么。然后他说：“好吧，很好，市长先生，”
continue with your speech. And the mayor very nervously gets through the rest of his speech. It's expected that Franz Ferdinand will reply. And of course, he's been practicing his Serbian, hasn't he? He has indeed.
“继续你的演讲吧。”市长非常紧张地完成了剩下的演讲。人们期待弗朗茨·斐迪南会做出回应。当然，他一直在练习塞尔维亚语，不是吗？他确实练习了。
The text of his response was in the car behind somebody has has followed and hasn't quite yet arrived with the speech finally this bloke arrives the speech has got blood on it from the people wounded in the car which has to be wiped off and at first franz fernand seems very agitated at the sight of the speech once again sophie puts a finger on his arm you know calm down and he's like yeah fine he wipes the blood away and he actually is capable unlike the mayor of improvising he says i consider that this welcome that you've given me is an expression of joy that that terrible attempt on our lives has been foiled and everybody claps
他的回应文本在后面那辆车里，有人跟在后面，还没来得及把演讲稿送过来。最后这家伙到了，演讲稿上沾满了车里受伤人员的血，必须擦掉。起初，弗朗茨·斐迪南看到演讲稿时显得非常激动，索菲再次把手放在他的手臂上，你知道，让他冷静下来。他就像是“好吧，没问题”，他擦掉了血迹，他实际上不像市长那样，他能够即兴发挥。他说：“我认为你们给予我的这种欢迎，是对我们生命中那次可怕的企图被挫败的喜悦表达。”大家都鼓掌了。
and then comes the great moment where he delivers his Serbo-Croat peroration. Yes. And it's absolutely banger, isn't it? Oh, it's brilliant. Standing in this beautiful capital city, I assure you our Slav and Mohammedan citizens of our august emperor's continued interest
然后就是他发表塞尔维亚-克罗地亚语结束语的伟大时刻。是的。这绝对是个重磅炸弹，不是吗？哦，太精彩了。站在这个美丽的首都城市，我向你们保证，我们尊贵的皇帝对你们福祉的持续关注，
in your well-being and of my own enduring friendship. And everybody again claps and thinks, brilliant brilliant and i think everybody at this point is think is genuinely thinking do you know what he is kind of scary with his hot temper and his walrus and his enormous ambiance and i hope he doesn't mistake me for a pheasant but he and sophie have shown the most unbelievable song that their bomb has been thrown at them the people behind them have been injured and yet they are keeping it together and continuing the visit and now they continue with the rest of the plan so sophie goes upstairs tom in that building to our left so that's the town hall the city hall she goes upstairs and the wives of the muslim dignitaries are going to
以及我本人持久的友谊。大家再次鼓掌，心想，太棒了，太棒了。我想此时此刻每个人都在真心实意地想：你知道吗，他那火爆的脾气、他的海象胡子和他的巨大气场确实有点吓人，我希望他不要把我误认为是一只野鸡。但他和索菲表现出了令人难以置信的镇定。炸弹向他们扔来，他们身后的人受伤了，然而他们却保持镇定，继续访问。现在他们继续执行剩下的计划。所以索菲上楼了，汤姆，就在我们左边的那栋楼里，那是市政厅，她上楼去，穆斯林政要的夫人们要
meet her and they want to remove their veils you see they they don't want to do that in public they want to do it in private that's her role as the female representative of the empire exactly she goes upstairs and it is clear that the attack is weighing on her mind the accounts we have of her is that she keeps mentioning to them her children and their family. She says of a little girl, she says, oh, look at her. She looks, she's the same height as my Sophie back at home. And then she says, oh, I can't wait to see our children. We have actually never left them for so long on their own and very soon we'll be reunited and I can't wait for it. Now, meanwhile, Franz Ferdinand, sean of sophie is back to his old tricks barking at people making inappropriate sarcastic banter so he says to one of his aides did you hear the bloke who
见她，她们想摘下面纱，你看，她们不想在公共场合这样做，她们想在私下里做。这就是她作为帝国女性代表的角色。没错，她上楼了，很明显这次袭击让她心事重重。我们得到的关于她的描述是，她不断向她们提起她的孩子们和他们的家庭。她指着一个小女孩说：“哦，看她。她看起来，她和我家里的索菲一样高。”然后她说：“哦，我迫不及待想见到我们的孩子们。我们实际上从来没有把他们单独留在家里这么久，很快我们就会团聚了，我等不及了。”现在，与此同时，没有了索菲的弗朗茨·斐迪南又回到了他的老样子，对人咆哮，进行不恰当的讽刺调侃。所以他问他的一位助手：“你听到那个扔炸弹的家伙了吗？”
threw that bomb tried to swallow cyanide what a fool he is doesn't he know that our criminal justice system is so lax they'll probably give him a medal and everybody kind of smiles weekly at this sort of daily express daily telegraph banter and then he says um maybe they'll have to give up lots of medals maybe when we drive back we'll have some more cougarin coming our way cougarin is a viennese dialect word that means little bullets maybe we'll have more and again lots of everyone again ha ha very good sir and then he actually turns to the governor oscar potiorek and he says well what do you think do you think people are going to shoot at me on the way back and potiorek says who is the guy who has said no security it's going to be fine potiorek says your highness i am sure this guy was an isolated lunatic
“他试图吞下氰化物，真是个傻瓜。他难道不知道我们的刑事司法系统太松懈了吗？他们可能会给他颁发一枚奖章。”每个人都对这种《每日快报》、《每日电讯报》式的调侃报以尴尬的微笑。然后他说：“嗯，也许他们得颁发很多奖章。也许当我们开车回去时，我们会遇到更多的‘小弹丸’（Kugeln）。”Kugeln是一个维也纳方言词，意思是小子弹。“也许我们会遇到更多。”大家又是一阵“哈哈，说得好，长官”。然后他真的转向总督奥斯卡·波蒂奥雷克，他说：“好吧，你怎么看？你认为人们会在回程中向我开枪吗？”波蒂奥雷克说——是谁说没有安保的？一切都会好起来的。波蒂奥雷克说：“殿下，我敢肯定这个家伙只是个孤立的疯子。”
that said i can't be certain even the best security in the world, which I provided for you, cannot prevent more attacks. Maybe we should ditch the original plan. Now, the original plan was to go back down that street that we're looking at, Tom, going along the river, the Apple Quay, and to turn off to see the new museum, the first in the city that the Austrians had built. Because I have to say, once you've seen the streets that stretch to the right of this main road, you'd think, I mean, that is a death trap. It's an absolute tangle.
话虽如此，我不能确定。即使是我为你提供的世界上最好的安保，也无法阻止更多的袭击。也许我们应该放弃最初的计划。现在，最初的计划是沿着我们正在看的这条街回去，汤姆，沿着河边，苹果码头（Appel Quay），然后转弯去参观新博物馆，这是奥地利人在城里建造的第一座博物馆。因为我必须说，一旦你看到了这条主路右侧延伸出去的街道，你就会想，我的意思是，那简直是个死亡陷阱。那是一团乱麻。
Yeah, the Tangler Valley is around there, exactly. The governor says, we'll go along the road, but we'll go straight back to the station. We won't turn off. We'll go along the Appalachee, keep going, and the station is at the end, and we can get the train. And Franz Ferdinand says, fine, we'll go straight back to the station we won't turn off go along the apple key keep going and the station is at the end and we can get the train and franz ferner says fine we'll do that the one thing i do want to do though the man who was injured in the car behind your adjutant
是的，那里的“纠结谷”就在那儿，没错。总督说：“我们会沿着路走，但我们会直接回车站。我们不会转弯。我们会沿着苹果码头一直走，车站就在尽头，我们可以坐火车。”弗朗茨·斐迪南说：“好吧，我们会直接回车站，我们不会转弯，沿着苹果码头一直走，车站就在尽头，我们可以坐火车。”弗朗茨·斐迪南说：“好吧，我们就这么做。不过我确实想做一件事，那个在后面车里受伤的人，你的副官，”
von merizzi i would really like to visit him in the hospital before we leave sarajevo the governor hesitates at that point like i'm not sure that's a good idea. And then Franz Ferdinand gets very cross, and he says, that man is my fellow officer. He is bleeding for me. You will have the goodness to understand that. You will have the further goodness to order a second car to take my wife
“冯·梅里齐，在他离开萨拉热窝之前，我真的很想去医院探望他。”总督在那一刻犹豫了，好像在说“我不确定这是个好主意”。然后弗朗茨·斐迪南变得非常生气，他说：“那个人是我的同僚。他为我流血。你最好明白这一点。你还要有进一步的善意，命令第二辆车带我的妻子，”
back to the hotel straight away. But Sophie's not having that. Sophie has come downstairs while he's been talking, and she hears him say that, she says no no way yeah i will come with you i am not going back to the hotel i'm not going to be separated i will stay by your side france fernand says fine so be it of course he's never going to argue with her we don't need the other car and this is the thing isn't it they're coming out from the relative protection of the city hall out into the sunlight into the open yeah street and i'm guessing they're kind of thinking is the description of the attacker as an isolated lunatic
“立刻回酒店。”但索菲不干了。索菲在他说话的时候已经下楼了，她听到了他这么说，她说：“不，没门。是的，我会和你一起去。我不会回酒店，我不会和你分开，我会留在你身边。”弗朗茨·斐迪南说：“好吧，那就这样吧。”当然，他永远不会和她争论。我们不需要另一辆车。这就是关键，不是吗？他们正从市政厅相对的保护中走出来，走进阳光下，走进开阔的街道。是的，我猜他们大概在想，对袭击者的描述是“孤立的疯子”，
correct or was it part of a consortium of assassins and if it was part of a consortium of assassins then this will be their chance. We'll be completely exposed. So it must have been an absolutely terrifying moment for them. And they come out onto the steps and there is no... There's just a crowd cheering them and clapping them. He takes her hand. There's a very famous photo of them coming out.
是对的，还是他属于一个刺客集团的一部分？如果他是刺客集团的一部分，那么这将是他们的机会。我们将完全暴露。所以这对他们来说一定是一个极其恐怖的时刻。他们走上台阶，没有……只有人群在为他们欢呼和鼓掌。他牵起她的手。有一张非常著名的他们走出来的照片。
He takes her hand and helps her down the steps. The car, the same car, is sitting there waiting for them. The Archduke gets in the car. Franz Ferdinand is on the left-hand side, the river side, if you like. Sophia sits next to him on the right. Governor Potiorek is in the jump seat. Ominous sign, Tom. Count von Harrach stands on the running board again now of course the attack had come from the
他牵着她的手，扶她走下台阶。那辆车，同一辆车，正停在那里等着他们。大公上了车。弗朗茨·斐迪南坐在左侧，也就是河边那一侧。索菲坐在他右边。波蒂奥雷克总督坐在折叠椅上。不祥的征兆，汤姆。哈拉赫伯爵现在又站在踏板上。当然，袭击来自
side nearest the river count von harak stands on the running board on the side nearest the river i the left hand side of the car had he stood on the other side of the car this whole story might be very different but he's on the river side they set off they set off and they're going to go down this road in front of us down the apple key all the way out of the city outskirts the city they're going to visit the hospital and then they're going to go to the railway station and then home and there is another photo that is taken of them after they've left the city hall going down this main road approaching the moritz schiller cafe which is what i, about five minutes walk from here.
靠近河的那一侧。哈拉赫伯爵站在靠近河那一侧的踏板上，也就是车的左侧。如果他站在车的另一侧，整个故事可能会大不相同。但他站在河边。他们出发了，他们出发了，他们要沿着我们面前的这条路走，沿着苹果码头，一直走出城市郊区。他们要去参观医院，然后去火车站，然后回家。还有另一张照片，是他们离开市政厅后，沿着这条主路行驶，接近莫里茨·席勒咖啡馆时拍的，那离这儿大约五分钟路程。
Yeah, I mean, if that. And it is there that the shot heard around the world will ring out. And I think that we should finish off the coffee we've been having as we sit outside the city hall and go to that very place.
是的，我的意思是，如果那是的话。就在那里，那声震惊世界的枪声将会响起。我认为我们应该喝完我们刚才喝的咖啡，当我们坐在市政厅外时，然后去那个地方。
Let's go. Right, so we've come to the Latinin bridge and dominic that i mean that took us less than five minutes so i'm guessing a car i mean no time at all they pull out of the city hall and in no time they are passing the moritz chiller cafe and delicatessen um it's now the museum but back then it would have been adorned with window stencils, adverts for wine and cigarettes and all the other stuff that you buy in an Austro-Hungarian Delicatessen. And it has German wording, doesn't it? And so that's made it a target for angry nationalists. That's right. Student activists. There was a big cutout on the
我们走吧。好了，我们来到了拉丁桥，多米尼克，那——我的意思是，我们花了不到五分钟。所以我猜车的话，我的意思是，根本不需要时间。他们从市政厅开出来，很快就经过了莫里茨·席勒咖啡馆和熟食店。嗯，它现在是博物馆，但在当时，它的窗户上会装饰着模板画，有葡萄酒和香烟的广告，以及你在奥匈帝国熟食店里买到的所有其他东西。而且它有德语标语，不是吗？所以这使它成为了愤怒的民族主义者的目标。没错。学生激进分子。那天，
day of a champagne bottle, a Hungarian champagne. It was attached to the facade of the cafe, kind of in celebration. The car, as you said, Tom, it must have taken a minute, absolute maximum. I mean, no matter how slowly they're going. Yeah. They roll up the street. They're probably now the second car in the motorcade. Again, you'll hear different accounts.
咖啡馆的门面上贴着一个巨大的香槟瓶剪纸，一种匈牙利的香槟。这是一种庆祝。那辆车，正如你所说的，汤姆，一定只花了一分钟，绝对最多。我的意思是，无论他们开得有多慢。是的。他们沿着街道行驶。他们现在可能是车队中的第二辆车。同样，你会听到不同的说法。
Now, what's not clear, the instruction was definitely given. We're not going to turn off at this point. We're going to keep on going towards the edge of the city to the hospital and the railway station. But there must have been some communication breakdown because nobody has told the driver of the lead car. He, at this point, right by the delicatessen, goes to turn right on Latina Strasse.
现在，不清楚的是，指令确实下达了。我们此时不会转弯。我们要继续向城市边缘行驶，去医院和火车站。但一定发生了某种沟通故障，因为没有人告诉头车的司机。他此时就在熟食店旁边，准备右转进入拉丁街。
And as he goes to turn right, he is going past not only the delicatessen, but Gavrilo Princip, who is standing outside. He has been waiting all this time. So this wrong turning that they are making they're making it past the one guy who is armed and ready to shoot exactly the first car turns right and that's got the mayor in it and the chief of police behind them governor potty oric sees it's turning right and he shouts out stop you're going the wrong way you're going the wrong way now there are different
当他右转时，他经过的不仅是熟食店，还有站在外面的加夫里洛·普林西普。他一直在等。所以他们正在做的这个错误的转弯，他们经过了那个唯一武装好准备开枪的家伙。没错。第一辆车右转了，市长和警察局长就在里面。在他们后面，波蒂奥雷克总督看到它右转了，他大喊：“停下，你走错路了，你走错路了。”现在有不同的
accounts depending which book you read and to be honest with you i haven't really got to the bottom of this it's a rare thing where we confess total failure and powerlessness on the rest is history some accounts say the cars stop and reverse others say the cars actually have no reverse gear at all yes i've read that so they have to be pushed back. What is certain is that Franz Ferdinand's car has actually followed the first car, has turned to the right, has only just turned to the right, turned off the apple key, going down by what is now the museum. And you were saying how Count Harak was on the side. Nearest the river. Nearest the river. So he is now on the side away from where princip is standing
说法，取决于你读的是哪本书。老实说，我还没真正弄清楚这一点。这是我们在《历史的休息》中承认彻底失败和无能为力的罕见时刻。有些说法说车停下来倒车，另一些说车根本没有倒档。是的，我读过那个。所以它们必须被推回去。可以确定的是，弗朗茨·斐迪南的车确实跟随了第一辆车，已经右转了，才刚刚右转，离开了苹果码头，沿着现在的博物馆旁边行驶。你刚才说哈拉赫伯爵站在哪一侧？靠近河的那一侧。靠近河的那一侧。所以他现在站在远离普林西普站立位置的一侧。
exactly so if you can picture the scene there is princip standing on the pavement then you have nothing between him and the car for just that split second where the car has stopped there is sophie on the right nearest to him and then there is the archduke franz ferdinand on the right, nearest to him, and then there is the Archduke Franz Ferdinand on the left. And in that split second, Princip realizes he is maybe too close or it's too much of a rush to throw the bomb. So he reaches into his pocket. He takes out that Browning semi-automatic pistol.
没错。所以如果你能想象那个场景，普林西普站在人行道上，然后在他和车之间什么都没有，就在车停下的那一瞬间。索菲在右边，离他最近，然后是弗朗茨·斐迪南大公在左边。就在那一瞬间，普林西普意识到他可能离得太近了，或者扔炸弹太仓促了。所以他伸手进兜。他掏出了那把勃朗宁半自动手枪。
He levels it at the car and he fires two shots. Almost at once, the car begins to move. The car pulls away. Princip can't see what has happened. As it's moving, the Archduke and Sophie are still sitting upright in the back of the car. He puts the pistol to his own head. It's part of the plan to kill himself. The crowd are on him, and someone grabs the pistol from his hand. And they also pull the cyanide capsule out, don't they?
他瞄准车身，开了两枪。几乎同时，车开始移动。车开走了。普林西普看不见发生了什么。当车移动时，大公和索菲仍然直挺挺地坐在车后座。他把手枪对准了自己的头。这是自杀计划的一部分。人群扑向他，有人从他手中夺走了手枪。他们还把氰化物胶囊也夺走了，不是吗？
They do. He puts it into his mouth, but then a policeman hits him. The crowd are grabbing at him. He is being beaten up by the crowd, and he can't finish the job and take his own life. And then he's dragged away. And the photo that is right now, as we said in the very first episode,
是的。他把它放进嘴里，但随后一名警察打了他。人群在抓他。他被人群殴打，他无法完成任务并结束自己的生命。然后他被拖走了。而那张照片，正如我们在第一集里说的那样，
the photo that is on the wall just there facing us of a man being dragged away, that is not Gavrilo Princip. Lots of people in the chaos are being dragged away because the police don't know what is going on. And in the chaos, Princip can't see what happened after he's shot, except that his last glimpse would presumably have been
那张挂在墙上正对着我们的照片，一个男人被拖走，那不是加夫里洛·普林西普。在混乱中，很多人都被拖走了，因为警察不知道发生了什么。在混乱中，普林西普看不见他开枪后发生了什么，除了他最后一眼看到的应该是
that the Archduke and his wife are both sitting upright. And so therefore he must have thought that he his last glimpse would presumably have been that the arch duke and his wife are both sitting upright and so therefore he must have thought that he had missed or he he'd failed yeah and this is what camp potty aura also thinks to begin with isn't it as they drive away that everything's okay that they're they're all right but probably the first four or five seconds after they've turned off it seems like everything is okay and then then the account that we have from which all other accounts derive so this is by um harak who's standing on the right and he writes as the car quickly reversed a thin stream of blood spurted from his highness's mouth onto
大公和他的妻子都直挺挺地坐着。所以他一定以为他——他最后一眼看到的应该是大公和他的妻子都直挺挺地坐着，所以他一定以为他打偏了，或者他失败了。是的，这也是波蒂奥雷克总督起初的想法，不是吗？当他们开车离开时，一切都好，他们没事。但可能在他们转弯后的前四五秒，看起来一切都好。然后，然后是我们拥有的所有其他描述都源自的那个描述，这是由站在右边的哈拉赫写的，他写道：“当车迅速倒车时，一股细细的血流从殿下的嘴里喷出，溅到了，”
my right cheek as i was pulling out my handkerchief to wipe the blood away from his mouth the duchess cried out to him for god's sake what has happened to you and at that she slid off the seat and lay on the floor of the car with her face between his knees so i'll tell you what's so moving about that she has actually been hit in the abdomen herself but what she says is not i've been hit but what's happened to you yeah i find that really moving actually well and likewise the archduke similarly when he sees her lying at his feet he says so full so full sophie sophie don't die stay alive for our children but she's do you think already dead by this point i mean she dies yeah very quickly i think she's probably already dead or dying when the archduke says that incredibly
“我的右脸。当我掏出手帕擦掉他嘴边的血时，公爵夫人对他喊道：‘看在上帝的份上，你怎么了？’就在这时，她从座位上滑落，躺在车厢地板上，脸夹在他的膝盖之间。”我告诉你为什么那段描述如此感人，她自己其实腹部也中弹了，但她说的不是“我中弹了”，而是“你怎么了”。是的，我真的觉得那很感人。嗯，同样，大公也是如此，当他看到她躺在他脚下时，他说：“索菲，索菲，索菲，别死，为了我们的孩子们活下去。”但她——你认为她此时已经死了吗？我的意思是，她死得很快。我想当大公说那句令人难以置信的
moving line actually yeah and so continuing harak's account at that i seized the archduke by the collar of his uniform to stop his head dropping forward and asked him if he was in great pain he answered me quite distinctly it is nothing his face began to twist somewhat but he went on repeating six or seven times ever more faintly as he gradually lost consciousness it's nothing it's nothing it's nothing but it is something because he has been hit in the neck yeah and it severed his jugular vein tom i mean we were talking about this the other day whether or not you know did he really say this he has been brought up in that world of total duty and not giving anything away you know the rigid world of the hapsburg court i absolutely believe
感人的台词时，她可能已经死了或正在死去。是的，继续哈拉赫的描述：“这时，我抓住大公的制服领子，防止他的头向前垂下，并问他是否感到剧痛。他非常清晰地回答我：‘没什么。’他的脸开始有些扭曲，但他继续重复了六七次，声音越来越微弱，随着他逐渐失去知觉，‘没什么，没什么，没什么。’”但确实有事，因为他的脖子中弹了。是的，它切断了他的颈静脉，汤姆。我的意思是，我们前几天还在谈论这个，他是否真的说了这句话。他是在那种绝对服从、不流露任何情感的世界中长大的，你知道，哈布斯堡宫廷那种僵化的世界。我绝对相信
that he would say it is nothing even if he's been hit and it's the most agonizing pain well i think his training is to deny any you of weakness, of human veeling. But against that, you also have the sentiment that husband and wife delivers to each other, which I guess, by the rigid standards of the Habsburg court, is a sign of weakness. But I mean, it has the absolute ring of truth, doesn't it? That they would each think about the other. Yeah. That line, stay alive for our
他会说“没什么”，即使他已经中弹，而且正处于最痛苦的折磨中。嗯，我认为他的训练是拒绝任何软弱、人类情感的流露。但与之相对的是，你也有夫妻之间传递的那种情感，我想，按照哈布斯堡宫廷僵化的标准，这是一种软弱的表现。但我的意思是，这绝对有真实感，不是吗？他们每个人都会为对方着想。是的。那句“为了我们的孩子们活下去”，
children i mean it's it's so moving actually yeah so the car now turns off so that's a tram going past memorial to the uh introduction of it by the hapsburgs yeah the car turns off comes across the river it's the governor's, the Konak. People immediately lift the two bodies out of the car. Their blood is all over the seat. Franz Ferdinand's valet, Count Morsi, was behind in the car. He has run all the way across the river, across the bridge to the governor's mansion to catch up with him. He cuts his uniform open because the uniform is so tight basically been sewn in exactly and there's blood pouring out of the uniform they put him on a bed inside the governor's mansion and mostly the valet says do you have any message do you have anything to tell your children but it's
我的意思是，这真的太感人了。是的，所以车现在转弯了——那是一辆电车经过，那是哈布斯堡王朝引入电车的纪念碑。是的，车转弯了，穿过河流，那是总督府，科纳克（Konak）。人们立即把两具尸体从车里抬出来。他们的血溅满了座位。弗朗茨·斐迪南的贴身男仆莫尔西伯爵在后面的车里。他一路跑过河，穿过桥，跑到总督府去追上他。他把他的制服剪开，因为制服太紧了，基本上是缝在身上的。没错，血从制服里涌出来。他们把他放在总督府内的一张床上，男仆莫尔西说：“你有什么遗言吗？你有什么要告诉你的孩子们吗？”但已经
too late franz ferdinand a moment later he breathes his last. He dies. And pretty much at the moment that he is pronounced dead, the bells are ringing 11 o'clock. So the whole business has taken less than two hours from the moment they got on the train to the moment of his death. It's been less than two hours. They lie out the bodies in the banqueting hall of the governor's mansion,
太晚了，弗朗茨·斐迪南片刻之后就咽下了最后一口气。他死了。几乎在他被宣布死亡的那一刻，钟声敲响了11点。所以从他们上火车到他死亡，整个过程不到两个小时。不到两个小时。他们把尸体停放在总督府的宴会厅里，
and they start to gather flowers. Frederick Mortonon in his book thunder at twilight says franz ferdinand and sophie died as they had lived in unison as we will see there is a there is a twist to that story and of course the other thing is they'd left three children whom no historian ever mentions actually their story i mean just to look ahead is remarkable yeah so next week we will get into what this means for europe because of course the question really with which we began this series was what was it about this assassination that made it different you know there have been lots of
他们开始收集鲜花。弗雷德里克·莫顿在他的书《黄昏时的雷声》中说，弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲死得就像他们活着时一样，步调一致。正如我们将看到的，这个故事还有一个转折。当然，另一件事是他们留下了三个孩子，没有任何历史学家提到过他们。实际上，他们的故事，我的意思是，展望未来，是引人注目的。是的，所以下周我们将深入探讨这对欧洲意味着什么。因为当然，我们开始这个系列时真正的问题是，这次暗杀有什么不同之处，你知道，以前有过很多
murders of royal figures uh their wives as well but something about this is different and next week we will be exploring what it is that's different but before we do that um and ending today's episode and this um period that we've been uh in sarajevo recording these past four episodes um should we just look and see you know what happens to the various participants in this story both princip but also what happens to the various participants in this story, both Princip, but also what happens to the bodies of Franz Ferdinand and Sophie, because actually there is one final awful twist. There is indeed. So let's start with Princip. Princip, he did bite on the cyanide capsule,
皇室人物的谋杀案，他们的妻子也是，但这次暗杀有些不同。下周我们将探讨到底有什么不同。但在我们这样做之前，嗯，结束今天的剧集，以及我们过去四集在萨拉热窝录制的这段时期，我们是否应该看看，你知道，这个故事中的各个参与者发生了什么，不仅是普林西普，还有这个故事中的各个参与者发生了什么，不仅是普林西普，还有弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲的遗体发生了什么，因为实际上还有一个最后的可怕转折。确实如此。所以让我们从普林西普开始。普林西普，他确实咬了氰化物胶囊，
but the cyanide, as we know, was degraded and useless. He was beaten and kicked and dragged off to prison. He's there by about 11 o'clock. He's covered in blood. He's bruised. He's being sick vomiting from the from the poison degraded as it is his associates were rounded up pretty quickly only
但氰化物，正如我们所知，已经降解且毫无用处。他被殴打、踢踹，并被拖进监狱。他大约11点就在那里了。他浑身是血。他伤痕累累。他因为毒药——尽管已经降解——而呕吐。他的同伙很快就被围捕了，只有
one of them got away the bosnian muslim Mehmet Basic he escaped into Montenegro the rest of them are rounded up within hours or days they all confessed quite quickly but they all told slightly different stories probably reflecting their different understandings yeah of the of the plot the one thing that princip always said to the austro-hungarian investigators was that he felt bad about sophie well because he says doesn't he that that he had paused fleetingly when he saw that she was in the car he said he had meant to shoot franz ferdant and Potti Urek and he didn't mean to shoot her. Of course, not much consolation. The police in total rounded up 25
其中一个人逃脱了，波斯尼亚穆斯林梅赫梅特·巴希奇，他逃到了黑山。其余的人在几小时或几天内就被围捕了。他们都很快招供了，但他们都讲述了略有不同的故事，可能反映了他们对阴谋的不同理解。普林西普一直对奥匈帝国调查人员说的一件事是，他为索菲感到难过。嗯，因为他说，不是吗，当他看到她在车里时，他曾短暂地犹豫过。他说他本意是想射杀弗朗茨·斐迪南和波蒂奥雷克，他并不想射杀她。当然，这没什么安慰作用。警方总共围捕了25
people. When the trial opened, it was here in Sarajevo on the 12th of October. By which time the world was at war. Europe was in flames. Princip at the trial never recanted, never, you know, he had obviously been caught red-handed. He was very upfront about his political motives. He explained precisely why he had wanted to kill Franz Ferdinand, because he was a threat to the ambition of a Serb-dominated Yugoslavia. He mentioned his reform plans and so on. On the 28th of October, Princip was found guilty of murder and high treason. But Princip was 19 years old.
人。审判于10月12日在这里的萨拉热窝开始。那时世界已经处于战争状态。欧洲陷入了火海。普林西普在审判中从未翻供，从未，你知道，他显然是当场被抓的。他非常坦率地说明了他的政治动机。他精确地解释了为什么他想杀死弗朗茨·斐迪南，因为他是塞尔维亚主导的南斯拉夫野心的威胁。他提到了他的改革计划等等。10月28日，普林西普被判谋杀罪和叛国罪成立。但普林西普当时19岁。
He had not yet turned 20. And there are kind of confusions, aren't there, with the various dating systems. And so the prosecution tried to prove that actually he's 20, but he isn't. So he can't be sentenced to death. And so they sentenced him instead to 20 years in prison under pretty brutal conditions. So he's to be denied food one day each month. And on the anniversary of his crime, he's to be put into a cell without any light. Yeah. He has to wear shackles all the time. Yeah. And I think worse of all for him, because he's such a bookish boy. Yeah. He's denied anything to read. Yeah. He's not actually a boy, though, is he, at this point? We always... I mean, I've said it many times.
他还没满20岁。各种日期系统之间存在某种混乱，不是吗？所以检方试图证明他实际上已经20岁了，但他没有。所以他不能被判处死刑。因此，他们判处他在相当残酷的条件下入狱20年。所以他每个月要被剥夺一天的食物。在他犯罪周年纪念日，他要被关进一个没有光的牢房里。是的。他必须一直戴着镣铐。是的。而且我认为对他来说最糟糕的是，因为他是个书呆子。是的。他被禁止阅读任何东西。是的。但他此时已经不是个男孩了，不是吗？我们总是……我的意思是，我已经说过很多次了。
The boy's arrived in Sarajevo. He turns 20 shortly after the assassination. He is a bad man, Tom. That's what he is. I don't feel sorry for him being denied anything to read. He had shot two people in cold blood. He died of tuberculosis in Theresienstadt Prison. Which will become a...
这个男孩到达了萨拉热窝。他在暗杀发生后不久就满20岁了。他是个坏人，汤姆。这就是他。我不为他被禁止阅读任何东西而感到难过。他冷血地枪杀了两个人。他死于特雷津监狱的肺结核。那将成为一个……
Later a concentration camp. He died in tuberculosis in Theresienstadt prison. So which will become a... Later a concentration camp. He died in April 1918. It is said that on the wall of his cell, he had written, our ghosts will walk through Vienna and roam through the palace, frightening the lords. It's a great line.
后来成为集中营。他死于特雷津监狱的肺结核。所以那将成为一个……后来成为集中营。他死于1918年4月。据说他在牢房的墙上写道：“我们的幽灵将在维也纳游荡，在宫殿中徘徊，恐吓那些领主。”这是一句很棒的话。
I actually, I'm skeptical. Where does that come from? So you often see it. I think it was written in accounts, when those accounts were compiled under Yugoslavia after the Second World War, 1960s, when people started to compile kind of folk tales about Princip that turned him into a hero of Yugoslav nationalism.
我实际上对此持怀疑态度。这是从哪儿来的？所以你经常看到它。我认为它是写在二战后南斯拉夫时期汇编的那些记录里的，1960年代，当人们开始汇编关于普林西普的民间故事，把他变成南斯拉夫民族主义的英雄时。
Very like the murderer of the Ottoman Sultan at Kosovo. Right, like Miloš Ovelic. Part of the continuum. Exactly, exactly. So that's what happened to him. Nothing good. He died before the end of the First Sultan at Kosovo. Right, like Miloš Jović. Part of the continuum. Exactly, exactly. So that's what happened to him. Nothing good. He died before the end of the First World War. Franz Ferdinand and Sophie,
非常像科索沃那个奥斯曼苏丹的谋杀者。对，像米洛什·奥比利奇。连续体的一部分。没错，没错。所以这就是发生在他身上的事。没什么好下场。他在第一次世界大战结束前就死了。弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲，
their bodies were taken by train to the coast and then on that ship that the guy had suggested they take up to Trieste and then by train to Vienna. They arrived there on the 2nd of July, the day after their wedding anniversary. Nobody from the dynasty was there to meet the funeral train, except for one person who we've actually talked about before on our podcast. This was the Archduke Karl, who would now become the
他们的遗体被火车运往海岸，然后在那艘那个人建议他们乘坐的船上运往的里雅斯特，然后乘火车前往维也纳。他们于7月2日抵达那里，也就是他们结婚纪念日的第二天。王朝中没有人去迎接灵车，除了一个人，我们之前在播客中提到过。这就是大公卡尔，他现在将成为
new crown prince and would in due course succeed Franz Joseph. So Karl, who's that, we talked about him with Eduard Habsburg. He's a very serious, dutiful, pious young man. And he is there to meet his relative's body. And so he's Franz Ferdinand's cousin, right? He is indeed. Franz Joseph, the emperor, was shocked by the assassination, but he wasn't sad. His daughter Valerie recorded in her diary, I found Papa amazingly fresh. He was shocked when he spoke of the children he had tears in his eyes but he wasn't personally stricken and when she said oh
新的皇储，并将在适当的时候继承弗朗茨·约瑟夫。所以卡尔，就是那个，我们和爱德华·哈布斯堡谈论过他。他是一个非常严肃、尽责、虔诚的年轻人。他在那里迎接他亲戚的遗体。所以他是弗朗茨·斐迪南的堂弟，对吧？他确实是。弗朗茨·约瑟夫皇帝对暗杀感到震惊，但他并不悲伤。他的女儿瓦莱丽在日记中记录道：“我发现爸爸出奇地精神焕发。当他谈到孩子们时，他很震惊，眼里含着泪水，但他并没有感到个人上的打击。”当她说：“哦，”
i think carl will do very well as the new heir he said very solemnly and emphatically for me it is a great worry less right in other words thank god that guy's out the equation yeah the funeral is unbelievable they lay in state for four hours. Thousands of people turned up in Vienna, but at midday sharp, the doors were shut and they were turned away. The two coffins were side by side, but in death as in life, Sophie was treated as a second-class citizen. Her coffin was placed 20 inches lower
“我想卡尔作为新继承人会做得很好。”他非常庄重且强调地说：“对我来说，这是一个巨大的担忧。”换句话说，谢天谢地，那个家伙出局了。是的，葬礼令人难以置信。他们停灵四小时。成千上万的人出现在维也纳，但在中午整点，大门被关上，他们被拒之门外。两口棺材并排摆放，但在死后就像生前一样，索菲被当作二等公民对待。她的棺材被放置在低了20英寸的地方，
than Franz Ferdinand's. Because she is being buried as a lady in waiting. As a lady, yeah. Franz Ferdinand on his coffin,, had the Archduke of Crown. It had helmets, swords, all of his medals. Hers, just a pair of gloves and a fan. The marker of her status. The marker of her status.
比弗朗茨·斐迪南的低。因为她是以侍女的身份被埋葬的。作为一名女士，是的。弗朗茨·斐迪南的棺材上有大公的皇冠。上面有头盔、剑、他所有的勋章。她的棺材上只有一副手套和一把扇子。她地位的标志。她地位的标志。
The emperor didn't send a wreath. No, Habsburg sent a wreath. I mean, President Wilson of America sent a wreath. Loads of ordinary people sent wreaths. No one from the dynasty sent a wreath. The funeral takes place at four o'clock that day. The children were not allowed. The reason was because they were more ganatic. They had been disbarred. They are not Habsburgs. It's Habsburgs only. So the children are not allowed at the funeral. The Kaiser, Franz Ferdinand's great
皇帝没有送花圈。不，哈布斯堡家族送了花圈。我的意思是，美国总统威尔逊送了花圈。很多普通人送了花圈。王朝里没有人送花圈。葬礼在那天下午四点举行。孩子们不被允许参加。原因是他们是“贵庶通婚”的产物。他们被剥夺了继承权。他们不是哈布斯堡人。只有哈布斯堡人才能参加。所以孩子们不被允许参加葬礼。凯撒，弗朗茨·斐迪南伟大的
friend. So he's coming out of this very well so far. He really wanted to come. And he was told, as were all other royals and dignitaries, do not come. They were given two reasons. One, security is too tight, security problems. But two, the emperor's health is not great. Actually, I think the real reason is that the Austrians are already debating what to do.
朋友。所以他到目前为止表现得很好。他真的很想来。但他被告知，就像所有其他皇室成员和政要一样，不要来。他们给了两个理由。第一，安保太严，有安全问题。但第二，皇帝的健康状况不太好。实际上，我认为真正的原因是奥地利人已经在讨论该怎么做了。
And they don't want other bigwigs there to muddy the waters while they get there. Do you think there's ever been a British podcast series or indeed any kind of series on the outbreak of the First World War from which the Kaiser so far has come out so well? I think it's unlikely. Yeah, I think it's very unlikely. The funeral service took less than 15 minutes they rattled through it the bodies were then locked away and the bodies were then moved out of vienna by train in the dead of night uh so basically to make sure there were no crowds and all of this they were taken across the daniel but midnight to franz ferdinand's family seat archstetten which is um in the vacau and so the whole reason for this is that in death as in life court protocol and the demands of
他们不希望其他显贵在那里搅浑水。你认为曾经有过英国播客系列，或者确实是任何关于第一次世界大战爆发的系列，凯撒到目前为止表现得这么好吗？我认为不太可能。是的，我认为非常不可能。葬礼仪式不到15分钟就结束了，他们草草了事。遗体随后被锁起来，并在深夜被火车运出维也纳，嗯，基本上是为了确保没有人群。所有这些，他们被运过丹尼尔河，在午夜运往弗朗茨·斐迪南的家族所在地阿尔特斯泰滕（Artstetten），它位于瓦豪地区。所以这一切的原因是，死后就像生前一样，宫廷礼仪和
hierarchy must prevail exactly there's no relenting it's staggering actually how even in this they will not give franz ferdinand sophie an inch it puts the refusal to lower the flag over Buckingham Palace half-mast when Diana died into perspective, as to be said. Now, there's a twist. They were buried at Archstetten, and they're still there. Sophie, because of her status, the children, as we said, are not Habsburgs. They are Hohenbergs. And in 1918 and 1919, when the empire collapsed and Austria became a republic, there was a Habsburg confiscation law. The Habsburgs were kicked out and their property was taken. The very rules that had hidebound their parents in life, they benefited from at this point. Their property was not confiscated and they were exempt from the law so uniquely archdetton castle is still in the family
等级制度的要求必须占上风。没错，没有妥协。令人震惊的是，即使在这种情况下，他们也不愿给弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲哪怕一英寸的让步。这让戴安娜去世时白金汉宫拒绝降半旗的事情显得相形见绌，不得不说。现在，有一个转折。他们被埋葬在阿尔特斯泰滕，至今仍在那里。索菲，因为她的地位，孩子们，正如我们所说，不是哈布斯堡人。他们是霍恩贝格人。1918年和1919年，当帝国崩溃，奥地利成为共和国时，有一项哈布斯堡没收法。哈布斯堡家族被赶走，他们的财产被没收。正是那些在生前束缚他们父母的规则，在这一点上让他们受益。他们的财产没有被没收，他们被豁免于该法律，所以阿尔特斯泰滕城堡至今仍归家族所有。
so i looked this up tom it belongs to princess anita of hohenberg who is the great granddaughter of franz fernand and sophie the tombs are still there today and you can go and visit that castle right now if you wanted to and the two boys i mean they grow up in austria through the 20s into the 30s and we've already mentioned therese and stat which becomes a concentration camp yeah and after the they actually get put in a concentration camp don't they they go to dachau i think one of them's there for six months one of them's for a bit longer than a year and they're put to cleaning toilets which obviously causes much hilarity to their guards. But they come out of it very well.
所以我查了一下，汤姆，它属于霍恩贝格的安妮塔公主，她是弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲的曾孙女。这些墓地至今仍在那里，如果你想的话，现在就可以去参观那座城堡。那两个男孩在20世纪20年代到30年代在奥地利长大，我们已经提到了特雷津，它后来变成了一个集中营。是的，他们后来确实被关进了集中营，不是吗？他们去了达豪，我想其中一个在那里待了六个月，另一个待了一年多一点，他们被派去打扫厕所，这显然引起了看守们极大的嘲笑。但他们最终平安无事地出来了。
They're much liked. Yeah, they were regarded as good chaps by the other prisoners. And they survive it. They do indeed. They're released. They survived the war. And I think they die in the 50s, don't they? Yeah.
他们很受欢迎。是的，其他囚犯认为他们是好人。他们活了下来。确实如此。他们被释放了。他们熬过了战争。我想他们是在50年代去世的，对吧？是的。
So that is the end of the Franz Ferdinand and Sophie story. Great friends of the rest of history, I think it's fair to say, Tom. I think so. I'm surprised. I mean, I always had him down as a baddie. Gavrilo Princip, on the other hand, not a man who I would welcome meeting in the afterlife. He's very much not a Sandbrook man. Not a Sandbrook man at all.
这就是弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲故事的结局。我想说，汤姆，他们是《历史的其余部分》的好朋友，这很公平。我想也是。我很惊讶。我的意思是，我一直把他当作坏人。另一方面，加夫里洛·普林西普，我可不想在来世见到他。他绝对不是桑德布鲁克会喜欢的人。完全不是。
It has to be said. But let's leave them in their unequal coffins. Because, Dominic, as they're being laid to rest, I think it is fair to say that the storm clouds of war are indeed gathering. They are. And our next episodes, we will be looking to explore this great issue. How is it that this assassination leads to such catastrophic consequences? And that will be the story we will be teasing out in our next series.
不得不说。但还是让他们留在各自不平等的棺材里吧。因为，多米尼克，当他们被安葬时，我想说战争的乌云确实正在聚集。确实如此。在接下来的几集里，我们将探讨这个重大问题。这次暗杀是如何导致如此灾难性的后果的？这将是我们下一系列节目中要探讨的故事。
Okay. So on that bombshell, Auf Wieder will be teasing out in our next series. Okay. So on that bombshell, Auf Wiedersehen everybody and Dove Virginia. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
好的。带着这个重磅消息，再见大家，多夫·弗吉尼亚。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的来源，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。